90 seconds.
OK.
I'm going to lose.
What's up?
I'm Marlon Wayans, and
this is 90 Second Trivia
with the Academy.
What do I win?
OK, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
What movie does Robert DeNiro's
famous line, "You talkin'
to me?"
come from?
"You talkin' to me?"
A Few Good Men?
Taxi Driver.
Rydell High School
is the setting
for which influential
'70s musical movie?
Grease.
It would be Grease.
(SINGING) Grease is the word.
Yeah, come on, more theater.
Julie Andrews won the
Best Actress Oscar
for which 1964 musical?
'64--
The one where she was
on top of the mountains.
What do you call it?
Sound Of Music?
Sound Of Music.
Mary Poppins, right.
What song did Aretha sing in the
1980 film The Blues Brothers?
"Think."
Oh, "Think."
Jodie Foster played FBI
agent Clarice Starling
in what 1991 film?
Silence of the Lambs.
That would be
OK, what was the
first feature animated
movie released in history?
Fantasia?
Mickey Mouse something.
It's a Disney one.
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs?
It's Snow White.
Yeah.
Which '90s movie has the best
selling soundtrack of all time?
Oh, come on.
I don't know.
The Bodyguard?
What is your favorite
Aretha Franklin song?
10 seconds.
"Ain't No Way."
"Dr. Feelgood."
You're supposed
to say, "Respect."
That's our joke.
"Respect?"
My song is "Respect."
R-E-S-P-E-C-T.
Yes.
Boom, there it is.
Time's up.
Yes.
Great job.